good evening members officers and
members of the press and public if we
have any I don't believe we do Charles
welcome to the cabinet extraordinary
cabinet meeting
a few
um
bits of housekeeping
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices of all
the stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in holy Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
as demonstrated here
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
Charles
the following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
item 3 councilor Auburn item 4
counselors Duckworth Bailey Sean and
Everett item five councilor Yates item
six councilor Yates item seven councilor
Everett
item 8 Council Auburn and councilor
Bailey
sorry
thank you chair I'd like to talk on uh
in relation to
20.1.4 please okey-doke
and Council Austin three four and six
please thank you
just update my notes one second
three four and sorry six okay
I don't have anybody under items nine
and ten is that correct
apologies for absence I have received
apologies from councilor cup
item two Declarations of interest does
anyone have any interest to declare in
the items of business on the agenda this
evening
item three future High Street fund to
introduce councilor pew
the aim of the future High Street fund
was to renew and reshape High streets
with the inclusion of other uses to
drive increases in football
the council was successful in a bid that
included the development of a creative
workspace in Ramsgate Town Center
unfortunately due to challenging
circumstances a number of buildings the
council has considered
and this cabinet have given authority to
purchase have either been brought or
leased by Third parties or landlords
have become unresponsive
since the council's been working hard to
identify new sites in order to be able
to deliver this project and one has been
identified that also
supported the delivery of the leveling
up fund project or part of it therefore
I would like to recommend the cabinet
one authorize the director of
regeneration to include the level and up
fund monies for the access to
Opportunities Town Center project to be
included within the future High Street
fund project for delivery the funding
allocated is approximately 250
000 pounds number two the cabinet gives
delegated authority to the director of
regeneration in consultation with the
interim director of property to complete
negotiations for the purchase of a town
center property within the approximately
1.31 million pounds externally funded
project
the funding allocated wouldn't will need
to deliver the purchase of the asset and
refurbishment in order to meet the
outputs of the future High Street fund
and level up fund project thank you
thank you councilor Pugh to speak under
20.1 first I have councilor Auburn
thank you leader um
it is a shame that um
that every effort has been made by uh to
council officers to gain uh
properties with within the High Street
in Ramsgate and and it's a shame that
they have fallen through
um I just want a couple of points of
clarification
uh the first point is
um obviously it's known as the future
High Street fund
but I think uh Council appears just
referred to what I'm not going to ask
but is it although uh
this fund refers to the High Street does
it actually cover the Town Center
that's the one
and the second question
is option 3.4 of the report refers to
leveling up money of 250 000 pounds
toward the project
uh can confirmation be given that this
leveling up money in inverted Commerce
there's not
um come from the leveling up fund aimed
at the port and the surrounding areas of
the port thank you
councilor Pugh do you have a response
for that I do thank you chair thank you
councilor Alban for your questions
um I would refer to our director of
regeneration in a second uh to answer
your questions properly I think I'd like
to reiterate and agree with you it's
been incredibly frustrating
um and I myself and I know officers have
been frustrated with uh the amount of
times that properties have fallen
through and the extensive search that
has gone on to to find
um suitable
venue or property or whatever you want
to call it to deliver this part of the
future High Street fund I think it's
been really uh really frustrating really
disappointing still see quite large
vacant retail units in the High Street
that are going to continue to be vacant
for quite some time and I would like to
to Really extend my thanks to the regen
team because this hasn't exactly been a
an easy thing to try and deliver it's
been incredibly frustrating and fingers
crossed uh we're coming to the end of it
and we can actually deliver on it but
I'll defer to our director of Regen to
answer your specific questions
thank you yes as you say it's called the
future High Street fund but the criteria
is about it being at Town centers and
renewing and repurposing Our Town
centers and drawing in footfalls so the
the site that we're looking at is within
the Town Center
um the second question in relation to
the leveling up fund monies so there are
there were three main projects within
the leveling up program one was around
the port one was around the harbor one
was about access to Opportunities and
investing in capital infrastructure to
enable people within some of our most
deprived Wards in Ramsgate to be able to
access the opportunities that were being
created through leveling up so this is
specifically for the one around the town
center and is some of the funding that's
allocated to that
um and and we will be delivering both
the outputs for leveling up access to
Opportunities and future High Street
fund at the same site
thank you Rita thank you
thank you
um to speak under 20.1 councilor Austin
thank you leader yes I share the
frustration that I know the Regeneration
team has experienced having worked as a
member of Ramsgate town team in the past
trying to get hold of properties just
for pop-ups and the like and the huge
difficulty that we faced even with that
so that they have my uh great sympathy
and admiration uh for sticking with this
and actually I do think that out of all
that frustration has come something
extremely positive
um I think the prospect of an employment
and skills Hub right in the Town Center
is a really exciting one particularly in
view of the extremely limited other
sorts of adult uh skills and training
Provisions that we have in Ramsgate as
compared to the other towns in thanet so
I do think that actually this is going
to fill a considerable Gap and my
question really is whether we've had any
discussions with say East Kent College
or even with KCC about what might happen
in the on the training side of that I
think particularly about the briefing
that we just had with from KCC about
co-location where I asked the question
of the KCC officer whether they'd had
discussions with our Estates team
because it seems to me that actually
there might be some collaboration
potential there and I wondered if any
discussions had happened as yet or if
we're we're still way before that thank
you
Council up here
I'll refer that straight to um to Louise
thank you thanks um so one of the things
that we're also doing alongside this is
I'm trying to put together the model of
operation so that it makes sense and one
of those things that will come out of
that will be how do we expect different
organizations to deliver activities in
there we um we've had a brief
conversation with those at KCC in the
property Department
um and said we do need to discuss
because there might be some activities
they're delivering elsewhere that we
could deliver from that space
um equally the college and other
training organizations those discussions
need to happen but what we didn't want
to do was preempt some of that until we
had a site and some of that will be
informed by what we can do within the
building and the designs
right thank you very much
thank you this uh recommendations one
and two has been moved do I have a
secondar councilor David Saunders do
members agree
item four future delivery of Port
Ramsgate to introduce that'll be me
Charles would you be so kind as to pass
out the
sweet just that
and Charles if you could
to because obviously cancer Sean was
speaking and uh
thank you Charles
the port of Ramsgate was designed and
constructed to serve roll on roll-off
ferries commonly known as roro and is
ideally located to offer short sea
Crossings don't say that when you've had
a drink between the UK and Europe since
1998 the council has operated the port
of Ramsgate which in the past has hosted
a scheduled cross-channel service
operating on a daily basis
however since April 2013 there has been
no scheduled cross-channel service
impacting on the ports financial
position
there have been there has been much
debate and commentary over recent years
about the fortunes of the port and its
future uses I'm pleased to be bringing
I'm delighted to be bringing this report
to cabinet which aims to address the
underutilization of the port and
recommends actions to attract new
businesses
the need to diversify the income gained
from the port is now is not a New
Concept and must have been done must be
done to expand its income streams over
the years
the aggregate business has been
established at the port for almost 25
years
With the Wind Farm operations and
maintenance bases being established from
2010.
there have been successes with ad hoc
businesses too most notably trade Car
Imports which have a positive impact on
poor income in recent years
it is recognized that to be successful
the port must attract resilient
businesses delivering stable income
streams and employment
using a specialist Port consultant and a
legal team a review of the post U EU
exit Market opportunities and options
for future Port delivery model models
have been completed
through this work seven options have
been identified for the future operation
of the port
at the heart of the report is a
recommendation for cabinet to approve
the option to bring in an operator to
manage the railroad activities at the
Port whilst retaining the management of
the part of the port plus split thus
splitting the commercial activity by the
type of operation
the council would retain control of the
non-rail Road Traffic including
Aggregates with railroad cargo and
traffic managed by a third party
this will give the council control over
how the port is managed and run by each
of the commercial entities operating
from the port but it would have less
risk and responsibility
a plan has been put together which is
annexed in the report which indicates
the area required for railroad operation
and an additional area that could be
made available if required by a
prospective pulse operator
this plan of the port builds up on the
zoning word the council completed and
established last year identifying
development sites for the port
the plan annexed in the report provides
a clear designation for the railroad
opportunities which
[Applause]
does not impact negatively on the
leveling up funding project to deliver a
green Campus on the northern part of the
port
the report sets out recommendations for
the route to procure the new railroad
businesses via a multi-stage open
process commencing with expressions of
interest from the market it will also
describe that
the current aggregate opportunity
therefore I would like to recommend two
cabinets
to approve the Future model for delivery
of the commercial pool as set out in
option 5 in the section 10 of the
cabinet report
recommendation two to give delegated
authority to the Chief Executive Officer
to develop the procurement framework and
process to be followed to secure a port
operator in accordance with Section 11
of this report
recommend recommendation three I would
like to move an amendment to the
original published wording
that reads as follows that cabinet gives
delegated authority to the CEO to
conduct an open and competitive
tendering process in order to make a
recommendation to Cabinet to secure a
pool operator based on the proposed
scoring criteria
following which the CEO is authorized to
negotiate and award a concession
contract and enter into an accompanying
lease in accordance with Section 11 of
this report
I would also like to move an amendment
to the previously published item 4 as
follows
that cabinet gives delegated authority
to the CEO to conduct negotiations with
the aggregate operator which will be
subject to the best value exercise to
ensure that the agreed proposals add
value to the port of Ramsgate the
council and its communities
negotiations will also cover any
requirements in terms of formal
approvals required being achievable for
the expansion
the agreed proposals will be recommended
by the CEO to cabinet for approval
following this the CEO is authorized to
enter into a subsequent contractual
agreement with an accompanying new or
revised existing lease with the
aggregate operator
a call upon
councilor Duckworth to speak under 20.1
counselor Duckworth
thank you leader
let's support the multi-purpose Port
hybrid option included in the report
in the port narrative document
references made to the co-location of a
university and business providing a
platform for innovation
and The Wider objectives of the Thames
Estuary growth board in relation to
hydrogen and low carbon Freight
given that there's a big difference
between blue hydrogen and green hydrogen
when it comes to achieving low carbon
Freight because blue hydrogen is made
from fossil fuel and is therefore not
very low carbon can I ask if we are
talking about Green hydrogen or blue
hydrogen here
thank you um
councilor Duckworth um
Louise can you respond to that thank you
as I'm not an engineer I don't have
technical answers to that but one of the
things that we are looking at and
talking to organizations like the 10th
District growth board and some of the
universities is creating that test bed
to
um understand what opportunities there
are for the decarbonisation around the
maritime sector so a lot of this is
still really at early stages and so I
can't answer your question completely
but what we're talking about is what the
opportunities are for that and other
renewable activities that kind of come
out of that green agenda
yeah cute it had nothing to do with um
the color
um being associated with the
conservative party but um there are
ports um especially in Europe that
actually don't call it the green energy
side they are in the port of Austin for
example they they call it all blue blue
energy especially as it's associated
with Marine so
um for some reason it follows through on
that as well but um not party related I
might add to speak under 20.1 I have
councilor Bailey
thank you leader
um yeah first of all can I say that I'm
not opposed to development report in any
form I grew up in a busy part of the
Thames which was industrial and it's
it's been sad to see that Paul you know
not making it's making full use of
um I do have I have a couple of
questions one's technical one's more a
concern
um I'm no expert but my understanding is
that
um Regular dredging is required to
enable ships over certain tonnage to
access landscape port
um and my question is if a ferry service
is resumed who would bear the ongoing
cost of the dredging
and my main concern is a question of
transparency and democracy really it
doesn't sit well with me that
um and I know you've changed in
recommend uh changed the recommendations
but it still Remains the Same it doesn't
sit well with me that that's such a huge
decision for than it will bypass elected
members to be decided by a chief
executive who we may know we may not
know I don't know sometime in the future
um so couldn't can you please explain to
me the reasoning behind this is it
common practice or is there a precedent
for this because I just feel as well as
denying Democrat democratically elected
members of voice the weight of this
decision on one or two people is is
quite onerous
thank you
um if I may
um
whole purpose of the amendment was to
give
the authority to the cabinet this is a
cabinet-led council and um
that is why he's been amended to to
Cabinet it's not one or two people it is
the cabinet of the council
um so that is why it's uh moved to that
stage it could be
um it's an operational
um it is an operational issue so
technically it could be officer's
decision right the way through the whole
thing but because we do have a good now
understanding between that's why it's
been moved to the cabinet decision but
ultimately that we are a strong
cabinet-based Council and that's why it
has been done like this
um
also I think yeah Louise you want to add
on that or do you want to come back onto
the dredging
okay
so in terms of your first point around
dredging so as a statutory Harbor
Authority we're already required to do
the dredging and we do dredge to a
certain level on the basis of the boats
that come in and out of the harbor as it
stands
um we are also the one that the port and
harbor Jews are paid to so that funding
is re or that those monies are required
to operate and maintain the reports
sorry the port so it would be our
responsibility but also is based on the
income that's gained
I think the chief exec also wants to
come back on on your second Point as
well yeah thank you leader just to
confirm that you know both decisions are
technically operational but absolutely
I'm very happy with the recommendations
being changed so that it all comes back
to Cabinet final decision I think it's
perfectly right for officers to conduct
the tendering process because that's a
very formal process driven Arrangement
but the final decision doesn't need to
be taken by cabinet I'm very comfortable
with her
next to speak under 20.1
um I've just got them in the order that
have been asked here so um councilor
Sean
I'll make a brief
for change
I fully support one previously are
trying to do to our Portland Rams mix
it's at its ups and downs
we must remember how many drops are down
there I have been in contact with
Brett's
because they should be able to defend
themselves in our work in Port
against all the untruth or truths
when we're talking about the dust and
cement
it's been down a long time
then we had the beast from the East and
not not talking about myself
that went all over the car windows
houses fan dust everything when you wash
your car down you've got that red dust
from Sahara
I've seen the operation down here I'd
like to know a bit more
they've got their own Depot down at
which the ball right next to the wet
fish shop there's no sand and grit on
the wet fish
but the potential at Ramsgate Harbor is
is wonderful so we should really grab
this and I'm quite happy to work with
anybody that's going to promote Ramsgate
jobs we've got baton full London away
we've got cannons boat builders that
would like to expand that's why last
time we had a briefing some of us should
maybe have more of a say but work with
our people that got the knowledge
The Maritime Museum
Thames Nursery vessels I lived there all
my life and changes along us Harbor arm
fair enough they're not nautical but
they have been taken over by wine bars
coffee shops extra and they're quite
vibrant
so on four ground effects for the
opportunity to work I mean I've had my
work in life the slit ways is another
issue but there is work continuing down
there it's not just it it's the best
Harbor in the world it's we haven't got
the same weather as they have in the
south of France but it's a working
Harbor I think I'll leave it at that but
uh
thanks for what we're doing and the
future around the state which everybody
in romantic I think is looking at a
future from MC although I don't just
talk about Ram today we're talking about
all this than it because it all means
jobs whether they come from Margaret
into landscape or vice versa and
railroad crossing
30 years ago and they missed that place
we could ever turn and throw there and
bring in investment
I'll leave it there thank you very much
thanks for my time
thank you Council strong and thank you
for your supportive comments
um to speak under 20.1 cancer Everett
yeah thank you leader and just to
address the the issue of the the
Democratic nature of the decision I mean
we've discussed this outside the meeting
and and my strong feeling was that the
decision needed to be made in a public
forum so that the public could hear the
arguments and I think we have to be
realistic you know the negotiating has
to be done by the officers to be honest
is it's not something counselors kennel
should be doing
um but it certainly should be done in
public and people should be able to see
and understand the basis of the decision
and members of the council can speak
under 20.1 and they can make the points
they need to make as indeed they will
tonight so um I thank you for the
amendment and certainly labor supports
that Amendment and thinks this is the
right way to do it not least because
this is just a continuation on a journey
that we set out on in the leveling up
bid in 2021 which as we all know was um
began under the labor Administration
and bringing back the railroad service
was very much part of that we asked the
government for this money the
government's given us this money it will
be extraordinary if we now turn around
and said no we don't want it because we
decided to do something else I don't
think that would be a good way of
approaching central government or it
would likely encourage them to give us
money in the future
um I support the auction has put forward
because I think it minimizes the risk to
the council and I think the
diversification of the pool is necessary
and a good idea
um I do understand the skepticism about
the the future of the railroad operation
based on the many mythical and ghost and
non-existent operators who've come
forward over the years but you know and
I know as Leaders of this Council the
council has received substantive
approaches from people who would like to
use the pool and have not been able to
do so because we didn't have the
infrastructure in place well under the
leveling up bib we will have the
infrastructure in place and we will be
able to take up those opportunities and
the fact is the government and the
industry experts that we've asked
believe that that demand is there and
the report of Ramsgate can operate again
and let's not forget that in the past he
did make a profit for the council and
I'm convinced he's going to make a
profit for the council in the future but
more importantly it's going to provide
jobs for the people of people of the
area it's going to be
um put back into proper use and I
actually think the people of Ramsgate
want to see the port used as a port
there may be skepticism about whether
the demand is there but most people in
Ramsgate are quite happy with the idea
that the port is a port and they don't
want to see it go down down some flight
of fancy which won't be won't
materialize into anything and this
opportunity to be wasted I think in
respect to Brett's
what this approach from bretts gives us
is an opportunity to try and renegotiate
the existing deal which has brought us
the birth four and five situation which
I think we all recognize is
unsatisfactory it's not the thought of
anybody in this room it's a it's a
historic contract which was entered into
by this Council and we can't really
endlessly go over the circumstances of
that or what we think about it we've
taken legal advice we can't get out of
it we've done what we had to do
um
so this is an opportunity to try to
breaks you want something from us well
we want something from you because we
don't want to be in a position in 20 or
30 years time of this Council having to
provide another birth for breath for
breaths so I think that that's something
that will come out of the negotiation
but most of all it's not a foregone
conclusion that they get these extra two
acres it really does depend on whether
it's the best use of the land from the
council's point of view if it can be
used better for the row row birth or
even for anything else then obviously
that's what we've got to look at not
just give it to Brett's because Brett's
have asked for it that's what this
recognition recommendation does that's
what this report does and labor is very
happy to support it thank you
thank you cancer Everett well
it's taken us nearly four years to get
together and agree exactly on on an item
so um we got there in the end but uh
yeah I mean it is absolutely vital in
vitally important and I think we can't
just think about it as as than it even
this is this is a strategically
important site port for the whole
country and going forward
um I think we have a duty to make this
work the government have shown faith in
it they're not going to just give you
that sort of money
um nylon nine nine million pounds to
actually
um I think it's nearly 10 million or if
you add it all up but um just for that
specific
um for the port itself and they're not
going to invest in that and you and it
would be churlish of us to say well we
thought about it but you know you can
have your money back and we're not going
to bother I mean this is a port and I
for one will love to see the fairies
coming in and out but my main
when I took over
um from as leader then this was always
my number one project to turn this port
around and I think if we can do that
whatever Administration is in to turn a
profit so that we can re we can um
recoup some of the money that that we've
lost over the years and turn it into
Revenue that we can then add to our
extra services for this District then I
think that's something that we should
all be proud of so
um thank you very much for your support
and I just look forward to maybe we'll
stand on the Dock of the Bay together
when the first one comes in so
well we've we've danced on burst four
five so we might as well dance on the
Dock of the Bay but uh anyway next to
speak under 20.1
um
councilor wing
thank you chair first of all I think
once again we all welcome the funding
and actually I do welcome the uh the
input of a diverse business on the port
because we can't be dependent on a Sole
Provider that if it goes bust we lose
everything so I do welcome the green Hub
and I do welcome the fact we're trying
to increase the diversity on the poor I
actually use the Sally line so I will be
buying a ticket I've vowed never to fly
so I will drive off or get a ferry the
smorgasbord was particularly great you
could eat an awful lot for 10 quid and
often I did I work I welcome the change
the proposals I think you've listened to
concerns that were expressed at the
members brief in and I welcome the
opportunity to speak here I'm afraid I
have a number of questions and I still
think they need to be asked because I'm
hoping that they will help inform
thinking as the process
unwinds and it now comes back to Cabinet
uh I I you know I I don't feel I've got
enough information and many of my
residents don't don't feel they've got
enough information as to understand why
we've delegated these Powers uh and so I
support uh Ruth to my side in her
concerns we are cabinet-led and the
cabinet has the powers to to make a
different decision uh but I'll leave
that one just hanging in the air because
I think you answered that two what
evidence has helped inform this decision
and can this be shared with all
councilors given the amounts of money
and the potential for future risk is
future risk that worries me greatly to
the council in terms of uh dredging was
uh mentioned I still haven't seen a
business case and in a business case I'd
like to see uh potential future risks
worst case scenario best case scenario
so we've got this Capital money to build
the infrastructure that will hopefully
attract people in but we will have to
sustain the running costs and at these
additional running costs just in my head
dredging extra staff in birth repair
replacement tugs Pilots I often saw the
trans Europa Ferry being Bank banked by
a a tug in high winds to stop it
actually going where it shouldn't go
has this been modeled for for best and
worst case scenarios and how will the
running costs be funded uh you alluded
to it you it would be part of the
procurement process so so I guess uh
stop me if you want to answer questions
as we go along or maybe I just leave
these hanging in the air and when it
eventually comes back to Cabinet
hopefully these questions will be
answered what will the concession look
like and given we will be going into
competition with other providers Not A
Million Miles Away how will we Safeguard
against a breach of UK and possibly EU
competition rules concerning I believe
it's state aid that could result in
legal action against us as happened to
the government over the Seabourn Ferry
procurement or should I say
non-procurement so hopefully our
procurement process will be tight enough
to avoid us
getting some sort of legal action from
other providers Not A Million Miles Away
what decision you're making powers does
this decision involve as indicated at
point two and three I know there's been
an update relating solely to the
procuring of the poor operator or does
this also involve decisions in relation
to infrastructure and future running
costs at point four in relation to the
extension of the aggregate business
presently at the pool that one worries
me because we all know that the present
provider withdrew an aggregate washing
plan I believe it was in maybe 2014 or
15 may have been 16. so is it just an
extension of importing of Aggregates or
are they looking to actually create the
gravel washer that they wanted to wanted
to put that necessitated a full planning
application through KCC
historic issues concerning the presently
something Council Everett alluded to at
least not offered to other a lease that
would be welcomed by most other
leaseholders in terms of its longevity
rent paid and responsibility for repairs
and Replacements of the asset how can
councilors and residents be certain that
a competitive lease knew or revised will
reflect the true market value
and my next question is if powers are
delegated to the CEO how can counselors
and residents be certain that all
appropriate planning Marine licenses and
eias are applied given the port and
harbor is located next to a highly
protected marine environment and
residents as close as 325 meters to
ensure we do not repeat historical
failings from 2009-10 when the batch
implant arrived we're all frustrated
with Southern water and what really
worries me is we could become the
polluter so we do need to ensure that
I'm hoping that the procurement of on
whatever is developed on the site will
be will be following all the necessary
legislation to ensure we're as squeaky
clean as we can possibly be
again what is the present aggregate
operator proposing is it more Aggregates
or is it a gravel washer
uh
the one-off cost we suffered as
indicated in the report
particularly trans Europa and unpaid
birthing fees how will we Safeguard
against a repeat of this
given it's very tight uh I would imagine
running a ferry business is a very tight
financial concern
uh I don't need these answers answering
now because you've introduced another
phase of possible scrutiny by us and the
decision comes back to us so I'm quite
happy for those questions to just hang
in the hang in the air and and be
thought about during the procurement if
if that's okay
thank you counseling obviously you have
a quite an extensive list there um
I don't know if that Louise can do with
Sam and Colin can do with some
um and um
obviously the I mean also if you if
you'd wish and prefer then to provide
your list and then we can come back with
full but I would also suggest that maybe
obviously the
the opportunity as well to ask questions
if it comes to scrutiny so
um I mean if it doesn't get called into
scrutiny then obviously
um we we would be we can answer them
outside of this meeting or we can answer
some now it's up to you I mean it's a
hybrid option for you so um would you
like to um well I mean given I mean I I
now think we've got the safeguarded bit
of it coming back to cabinet that makes
me feel a lot happier so there's that
there's that initial level of scrutiny
that is available to all councilors so I
really do welcome that and thank you for
listening to the concerns expressed by
people across party it wasn't just the
greens banging on so so I'm quite happy
to provide you with a typed up list of
my my questions they don't have to be
answered now maybe they'll be considered
as the process unfolds
I think that'll probably be per and then
you can come back unfortunately
um Mike Humber can't be with us this
evening
um he has a family emergency so um I
think it will be better if you could do
that because some of these questions are
quite Technical and he's definitely our
technical brain no disrespect to the
chief executive and to Louise
um
and I certainly um I would like to I
would like to disillusion you that uh
that it wasn't actually the members it
was actually councilor Bob bayford that
requested this amendment to the wording
so I think you have him to thank for
that not versa
[Applause]
32 years
[Laughter]
yeah I do listen to sometimes and I I
think it was right I mean it it's
obviously I
back in the day and I'll be I'll be
quite honest here back in the day then
you know obviously the alarm Bells would
have gone up but I have a lot of faith
in our chief executive and all of our
statutory officers and all of our
officers so it sort of felt very
comfortable with me and this is very
very technical
um there has been a lot of reporting
there is actually a 70 page
study behind this which can be made
readily available it makes very heavy
reading but I can assure members and the
public and anybody that that wants to to
listen is that you know like I said to
councilor Garner the other night
someone's going to be right and
someone's going to be wrong
um and we we will know
um quite shortly hopefully once there
once the offer goes out there and and
the bids come rolling in then uh
hopefully I mean the main object to the
exercise is that all of our assets that
we have they either have to work for us
or they have to go we can't carry any
more and that goes for every single
asset within our Estates in this Council
we have to be become more
self-sufficient and over the years
as the years go by it will be more and
more necessary for us to do that and and
I'm convinced that this is this will
turn the port around and it will bring
some income and I look forward to
spending the extra revenue for whichever
seat I sit in when when the first check
gets written through so um I think um I
don't know if you wish to just some
summarize a little bit but um I think we
have uh obviously the the procedure for
counseling to submit it in writing but
if you want to just do a bit of a quick
overview Louise ladies first
thanks yeah I just wanted to say that I
mean there's been quite a significant
amount of advice that we've sought from
Specialists including in ferrata and and
their report is attached to the uh the
main report and also some really
specific legal advice around the
procurement and Concession process and
we've tested the different kinds of
processes that we might go out to the
marketplace and this um staged process
seems the best in terms of being able to
get the best thing for Ramsgate
um we are developing a section of FAQs
on the website so your questions will
help some of that we can answer those
and and there'll be more information
online so that'll be over the next
couple of weeks that we're starting to
pull that together and so that we can
help answer some of the questions that
are coming out of this I really think
it's quite a full report in terms of the
information that's been put in there to
try and help deal with some of those
questions because obviously a lot of
information has been supplied to the
council from um the Specialists and
experts that we've been working with
with and I think the point around the
Brett's proposal for the um in the in
terms of the Aggregates is we've still
got to go through a process and I think
we talked about that a members briefing
um and and Collins alluded to that in
terms of that process of engaging with
them so there is there are still some
unknowns around that and that's where we
need to make sure we do our due
diligence and that's what we will be
doing as part of this process so but um
your questions will help us develop
those FAQs
thank you I just I just like to add
thank you but I just like to add I don't
think it's who's right or who's wrong I
think it's just about us as a council
making sure we get the best we can for
for the money we've got and also we
don't we don't actually end up with some
liabilities so whoever's right and
whoever's wrong is totally irrelevant I
think all we want is the best for our
community and for for the assets we've
got
just to agree I think this is an amazing
opportunity in this one we should grab
um uh has I think councilor Everett said
the money is available for the first
time to actually make the port work
um and it would be criminal if we
weren't take that opportunity just
generally speaking in terms of the
advice we've got
um we've had in frata but we also have
commissions some lawyers who've got
specialist knowledge about ports and how
they operate so we're going to be
advised all the way through this
so fingers crossed we'll be able to come
back with a really good proposal for you
to agree
so last to speak under 20.1 councilor
Austin
thank you leader I'm not going to talk
about the specifics of the port and the
and that aspect with Council wing and I
have divided this up I'm looking at the
process of decision making and how we've
got to where we are
um and I the first thing I want to say
is I welcome the opportunity to turn the
port around in whatever shape or form
and the second thing I wanted to say is
I've very much welcome the fact this is
coming back to cabinet because I was
really worried about about it not doing
not because I have any disrespect for
the chief executive and the senior team
but because I think democratically that
is the right thing to do and on the
issue of democratically being the right
thing to do I wanted to pick up on
councilor Everett's comments at the
members briefing
um nine weeks today I expect many of us
will be standing outside polling
stations and I'm hoping it'll be a great
deal warmer than it is this evening
um it seems it feels to me that this
process success has gone very very
slowly and all of a sudden is being
rushed through immediately before a
local election and I think the Optics of
that are worrying for residents I don't
know whether there's anything that can
be done about it but I think the Optics
are worrying
um I am delighted to see in the infra to
report a SWOT analysis we've been asking
for a SWOT analysis for some
considerable time along with business
plans and it's great actually to see
that looked at but the options that
infrar to look at don't actually include
the full range of options that we've
considered over the years and I
understand that that's because we've
applied for funding for a particular
set of proposals but it feels a bit like
Patel's making the dog we've applied for
funding for something therefore we've
excluded a whole series of other options
and actually in frater themselves say
whilst the report provides some guidance
as to the best options to pursue based
on known options it's important that all
possible options need to be exhausted
before providing a final decision and
I'm I'm interested in where the cabinet
feels that we have actually explored all
the options that we need to and that
we're not going backwards about this I'm
also concerned about whether we have
followed the principles of of decision
making in terms of openness and
transparency counselor shonk mentioned
that and I think that is a concern that
residents have have we got all the
information are we putting all the
information out there I was pleased to
hear Louise talk about the FAQs on the
website and the questions that come up
informing those because many residents
are very concerned about making sure
that we're not taking on liabilities
that we don't end up in a situation that
we've ended up in previously with trans
Europa Etc so um and on that issue the
Brett's matter obviously is a concern
for residents in particular the fact
that we said when we put a larger birth
in that we had no expectation that
breasts would expand and now Brett's are
interested in expanding funny that
um so I I think we need as much
information as we can for residents and
for members I would have liked to have
seen this come to full Council but I
accept as leader has pointed out that we
have a cabinet-led system and I'm very
pleased to hear that it's coming back to
cabinet and I would like to see as much
information as possible at every stage
Hereafter obviously there are commercial
confidentiality considerations as the
process continues but as much
information for members and there's much
information for members of the public
residents and businesses as possible
Hereafter on on this map matter thank
you
thank you
I think I can cover the election bit
um
I've been working on this since I sat in
this well stood in this seat in June
when we were lucky enough to um
persuade the chief executive to come and
take care of us
over here in thanet I gave him a list
and said oh welcome to chief executive
um and we want to do the following
and number one on my list was Paul
Ramsgate now that was nearly two years
ago so there has been a lot of work
that has that has gone into this and
it's not something
I won't win an election on whether or
not
the ferries come in and out I'm doing
this because I believe it is the best
thing for thanet and where I'm in
agreement obviously with Council Everett
is is the way for us to
Turn Around The Fortunes of the port to
bring to secure the jobs that are
already there but also bring some extra
jobs into the area which obviously has
extra add-on on the benefits
um and really that's what it's all about
this isn't about elections this isn't
about politics this is about what is
doing the right thing well I believe in
the cabinet believe is the right thing
for this for this District
um and like I said earlier it's not just
for the district it's a national thing
as well so you know we have a duty
really to utilize National
infrastructure sites that are of input
National importance to try and make this
work and
you know there has been so much work
gone into this but it it only appears to
be rush now because we've come to the
end of the process where we are and you
know the the whole point is that the
paper recommends option five you know
the extensive work that's gone through
and option five is
understandably the least exposure to
this Council which will generate income
I mean a lot of the questions and you've
got to understand I mean it is complex
and and I've got the advantage obviously
of being with officers uh right the way
through the process
um I mean I've learned things that I
never dreamed that I would learn but
the the whole point is is that as a
council it would it's virtually
impossible for a council to run a port
because of the expertise that is
required you know the poor operator be
the one that has to have the expertise
and quite frankly why are they going to
come in it's a bit like renting a shop
if you don't think you're going to sell
anything then you don't rent the shop so
you know in in basic analogy but uh that
is the truth these people are the
experts it is it is a very detailed and
uh technical area but and it's a it's a
moving Feast you know 10 years ago
it wouldn't have been viable but now the
whole Market's changed everything's just
in time everything you know is is in and
out there's a lot of there's a lot of
freight and the EU has changed things
and you know the whole Market is
completely different now so this is a
golden opportunity this is our window if
we miss this window then we might as
well just say goodbye to it and and
obviously the money from the government
is the is the deal breaker if we haven't
got that then we wouldn't have been able
to do this I'd love to have done it but
we wouldn't have been in a position to
do it so
um if that reassures you but it
certainly is not a a an election thing
at all it is purely because this cabinet
believes it is the right thing to do and
that is why we're going forward with it
um
slot analysis
um have we explored I mean
probably I would say that that slot the
analysis has been explored so it's death
but um I don't know if Louise
or the chief has got something on that
um the principles of openness again
um I think that's the the chief execs
area and Brett's
um
the bus was uh
uh I'm not sure there was uh sorry I
forget your your phrasing there was that
we said that they wouldn't expand
um
this yeah I mean but the the the the
point is is that this is um this is just
the holding area for aggregate it's not
them expanding the operation per se but
this has come about because the because
the
the quarries of run dry and a lot of
um a lot of the aggregate now has got to
be seed Ridge
so in a way it is is helping if you like
the carbon footprint of cartoon
Aggregates around on land because this
is going to come straight from sea to
shore so if we're looking at the big
National carbon footprint principle then
actually this is this is a plus because
um
you know I don't know how much uh I
don't know how much the ships bring in
but it's a lot of Lorry loads uh so I
might sell a black then didn't I but uh
that's that is that is the case so you
know we have to look at the big picture
you know we can't be precious about the
port the port belongs to the whole
nation and we and we must do the best to
make it work for everybody not just for
us financially but for also for the
logistics of the country so
um Chief exactly I don't know if you've
got to uh
about the principles of openness
um well I think we've been as open as we
can possibly be I mean if you read the
whole report and the annexes and the
background papers you're doing
incredibly well
um and I think that's why we're putting
the FAQs on the website and of course
late last year we put a narrative on the
website about what we're trying to
achieve you can always do more but I
think you know if you read the report
you should get all of the information
you need to actually realize why we're
taking the decisions Beyond I was just
going to make a point on the timing
um I understand where you're coming from
and I think you talked about the Optics
as opposed
understood that from my point of view
the Practical problem is that if we
don't take a decision in March we have
to wait till June it's very unusual but
the local election gets in the way and
we have love funding that we have to
spend my particular date and it would
obviously be logical to spend the love
funding on the infrastructure as we work
our way through the procurement process
and we know what it is we're looking to
deliver with a new Port operator
so if we don't get on with it then we're
going to be dangerously close to
choosing an operator and spending money
on infrastructure which the new operator
doesn't need
which wouldn't be sensible so that's
where we're coming from in terms of
Brits took us by surprise as well this
has been quite a recent issue that
submerged it would probably normally
have gone to a different cabinet with a
different report
we just took it to this cabinet because
it's an issue and we wanted permission
to begin negotiations so it's not
directly related to the separate issue
of the port operator but we covered it
in one report
uh uh right gotta think where I am now
right I think everyone's spoken down to
20.1 so
um cabinet I have
moved the option five with the various
authorities and and items one two three
and four have been moved so I'd like a
secondary councilor Rhys Pugh
to Cabinet agree
unanimous Charles thank you
item
five
my hands are so cold I can't turn the
pages over
so item five is better care fund update
to introduce councilor Jill bayford
thank you leader
the council has a statutory Duty toward
disabled facilities grants I'll refer to
them as dfgs because they come up a lot
to people who qualified for assistance
subject to means testing
dfg's fund essential adaptations for
people with disabilities designed to
enable people to continue to live
independently in their home
in the past funding for disabled
facilities grants came directly from the
government
now the funding for dfgs is part of the
better care fund
the better care fund is a pooled budget
across district and County councils and
Health Services
the fund is administered by KCC and is
available to be spent on things which
contribute to the better care fund plan
including including dfgs
the purpose of including the DFG funding
in the BCF was to enable spending on
wider joint housing Health and Social
care outcomes such as reducing Hospital
emissions and enabling earlier discharge
from hospital
the first call on the council's BCF
allocation is the funding funding of
mandatory disabled facility grants
however there is scope to also fund the
administration of the grants program and
other services that are set out in the
council's published housing assistance
policy
TDC currently uses some of our better
care funding to fund the disabled
felicities facilities grants officer and
a case KCC occupational therapist to
support disabled people who need
adaptation
we also find our handyman we also fund a
handyman screen Hospital discharge
scheme and a specialized hoarding
officer all aimed at improving outcomes
for vulnerable and disabled residents
we also fund two offices within our home
energy team whose role is to provide
advice about Energy Efficiency and
available funding and to support people
in fuel poverty to access the help they
need
there remains some capacity within the
better care fund to allocate further
resources to these Services as set out
in the report
it is recommended that additional
resources are needed for Energy
Efficiency work due to the scale of the
need for this work as a result of both
the declared climate emergency and the
current economics climate
I recommend that the cabinet note the
report regarding the current use of
better care fund and approve the
additional resource within the housing
strategy and projects team for home
energy
thank you councilor bayford speak under
20.1 Council Yates
thank you thank you leader and thanks to
the officers for producing the report in
front of us today and thank you to
cabinet for um
agreeing to the recommendations and the
officers um it's shocking to once again
read that we have 20 fuel poverty in
thanet and um
uh under and it's and it's important to
know the referrals the home engine team
have increased by 200 over the last year
um so it's great to see that this
recommendation recommendations being
taken forward and fully support that
decision thank you very much
thank you Council Yates
um I mean this is a very serious issue
um and um
this will be
a great assistance to to this area so
um councilor bayford you have
recommended and moved the item thank you
councilor yes for your comments and this
is clearly a very good use of the better
care fund what is a very difficult time
for many better residents thank you
thank you councilor bayford sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off there so you
have moved uh do I have a secondary
councilor David Saunders do members
agree
item six is net zero strategy and action
plan to introduce councilor Bob bayford
yeah thank you chairman uh TDC Net Zero
strategy sets out how we will address
climate change and meet our pledge which
includes reaching Net Zero in our
Estates and activities by 2030.
the draft strategy was approved for
public engagement last September the
engagement process ran until the 11th of
November and was very successful with
over 70 residents and organizations
giving feedback
this feedback summarized in the attach
report which includes a table listing
the themes of the comments made and how
TDC will take these comments on board
the engagement process has led to a
number of recommended additions to the
strategy these recommendations were
presented to the climate change cabinet
Advisory Group which has cross-party
membership and the group agreed that
they should be taken to cabinet
final draft of the Net Zero strategy
2023 and feedback report will be
available on our website for residents
to view it's a brightly colored and
engaging document and will help us all
to address the climate emergency
I would like to recommend that cabinet
approves the proposed recommended
additions to the Net Zero strategy which
are to add interim targets to 2030 and
2040 for the emissions the council has
partial control over in the next action
plan this action plan will be written in
2024. to add the emissions from homework
into future carbon footprinting
calculations to consider calculating
emissions from staff commuting when
resources become available to collate
the more complicated data set to work
with KCC on local area energy planning
to devise a plan for renewable energy
across the district where resources
allow and to set out a clear plan to
ensure that all staff are educated on
climate change
also the cabinet approves final Net Zero
strategy 2023 and the cabinet continues
to note that the strategy cannot be
fully implemented without external
funding being available and agreed in
accordance with the pledge to Lobby
external agencies and government
thank you councilor bayford
to speak under 20.1 I have Council Yates
thank you leader fully support this
proposal tonight I'd like to thank the
climate change officer and other
officers across the council for their
support in working towards this
important Target I just want to
highlight
recommendation three that says the Net
Zero strategy cannot be fully
implemented without external funding
so my question is are we going to
contact the government at this stage and
if so can the council publish any
correspondence and any response we might
get from the government thanks
thank you councilor Yates councilor
bayford
do or counselor scott.scott
thank you um at the moment we haven't
got any
um letters or communication with the
government with regards to the funding
we did last year send a letter
um explaining that there are a number of
barriers and we we sent this through KCC
as well so all the councils got together
to send this letter to the government
um so they do know that there are a
number of barriers but there's not a
specific letter that we're sending
currently
okay I'm sure if you wanted to put one
together councilor Byford and Dr Scott
then I can add it to my weekly
dispatches to Westminster
um I have a regular bag that goes up
with the letters in so
there is there could be a bit yeah um
councilor bayford do you wish to come
back
I mean I would just like to come back to
council Yates I mean I mean we've
recognized right from the beginning that
we need other money you know we we
haven't got the money to do what needs
to be done and I can just assure him
that you know certainly this
Administration will do all it can and
I'm sure future Administration as well
and hopefully because it's so important
that government will actually see fit to
make funds available for the very
important work that was going to need to
be done
um I think the 151 officer would like to
come in thank you leader just wanted to
add
um to what's already been said we do
actively look and consider grant funding
that's available already for us to apply
for so for example uh the social Hearts
housing decarb fund is something that's
been considered um when we've been
looking at the necessary works that's
needed to be made to our tower blocks or
another elements of our housing stock
and we'll be considering either grant
funding streams as and when they come up
[Music]
having the equipment available to
actually to be able to do the work I
think when we ex when we um ventured
into this a couple of years ago we
couldn't deliver it because basically
every single Council in the country
applied for their money got the money
but there was no actual Engineers to be
able to install it and the actual
equipment or the parts necessary to to
be able to decarbonize a building the
the elements weren't available so um I
think the government also needs to look
at the supply chain it's no good giving
us money and then we can't actually
deliver the product because there isn't
the product out there so they need to
look at both ends of the chain so we
could probably remind them of that as
well I think we did the last time
Council Austin I think uh 20.1 thank you
thank you and picking up on that point
um I think this huge potential with our
green Hub at the port to look at other
forms of training there that there's
there's so many jobs going to be coming
up in this field and so many people
who've got some of the skills and could
be trained up to to fill some of those
vacancies so it really there really is
huge potential there I think the the
thing I wanted to say was very similar
really to what council Yates said it's
an excellent strategy really pleased to
see how many positive and constructive
comments we've got from residents and
really pleased to see that those are
being built into uh that our plans
um particularly good to see the idea of
interim targets so we can measure how
we're going along
um the the sort of setting up the
community group and comms plans and so
on I think there's the sort of you said
we did approach is to comms it's going
to work really well here because
residents will be able to see that what
they have suggested has actually been
built into that it shows the council as
a responsive Council that really wants
to work with its Community which is
which is great
um and um I was interested in the
training for officers because I wondered
whether there was potential for training
for members and whether actually that
might be something that we could do
together
um as part of the sort of team building
approach that we talked about as a
result of the independent monitoring
officers recommendations and so on there
are a number of things where perhaps we
might be working together and um and uh
be part of the same training that could
be useful to both new and existing
members and officers that was all thank
you thanks and thanks very much to
everybody who's worked on this it's it's
excellent it's moving forward very
encouragingly thank you
councilor Beauford
an interesting concept that members and
officers should be trained together
might be I mean I think something needs
some thinking about because it might be
that you need different emphasis so I've
given our different roles but certainly
something to think about
shared information certainly yeah
absolutely and I mean I think you're
absolutely right
um you know the fact that we've got as
much feedback as we had it has generally
been positive
um Dr Scott's been able to incorporate
it in into the the
proposals here tonight
um and I think you know it's one of
those things I mean it's a fairly new
area for the council to get involved in
um and I think the strides that we've
made with very limited resources again
thanks like it to Dr Scott it's quite
incredible and it's good to see that
people appreciate it so thank you
thank you I think we're certainly
leading the way from a lot of councils
with our
you know sun is fast becoming the
leaders I mean gosh what happened you
know what a transformation we've seen
anyway
um I think maybe we've already started
our training because we're all sitting
here in overcoats and I don't know was
this a was this was this applied Dr
Scott for us to get off on the on a on a
minus minus basis
um so
oh
yes
so
um where was I oh so you've um you have
moved this um
do I have a second uh
do members agree
item seven proposal to transfer land
area of land off Highfield Road Ramsgate
to the housing revenue account for
development of affordable for of
affordable housing to introduce
councilor Jill bakeford
thank you leader the land of Highfield
Road is a small site with an initial
assess capacity for up to 27 homes
the site has already been allocated for
a residential use within the planet
local plan
the site is situated close to the
existing residential dwellings in
Highfield Road Ramsgate and directly
adjoins the back Gardens of existing
houses
it is also adjacent to the sports
facilities at Jackie Baker's and has
previously been used as parking linked
to the sports provision the area is
currently fenced off and unused
initial planning advice is that a
smaller scale development of
approximately 20 homes would be more
suitable
independent valuation advice has been
obtained and is set out in the report
the final value will depend upon the
final scale of the consented scheme once
planning permission has been obtained
where a property is transferred between
the HRA and any other revenue account
within the general fund a corresponding
adjustment to the capital financing
requirement is made between accounts
this has the effect of reducing the
level of debt allocated to the council's
general fund and the revenue cost of
supporting this debt potentially making
future general fund capital investment
more affordable
[Applause]
the affordable homes to be provided on
this site are very much needed in thanet
the council's most recent housing needs
study identified that our district needs
needed 548 new affordable homes each
year to meet the needs of our local
economy economy and the council's house
building program makes an important
contribution to this
in November 2022 cabinet reviewed the
council's housing development program
and agreed to allocate an initial 7.9
million to a phase five program we've
potentially delivered to deliver 25 to
30 units in the financial year 2526
the site of Highfield Road would make a
significant contribution to the living
with delivery of this commitment
I would like to recommend that the
cabinet um
agreed to the transfer of land from the
general fund account to the housing
revenue account to enable it to be
developed for affordable housing
to prepare and submit an application for
planning consent for the development of
affordable homes including necessary
technical site assessments and Community
consultation
and to consider a further report to
authorize the letting of Construction
contract once a detailed scheme has been
developed
I
move the recommendations set out in the
report
thank you councilor bayford to speak
under 20.1 Council Everett
thank you leader and one surprise you
that we're always going to be in favor
of new homes that are affordable to our
residents and therefore very happy to
support the transfer to the HRA I was
quite interested in this piece of land
because as you're probably aware when
this first appeared on the formal plan
there was a bit of excitement and I
think that's because residents got the
impression that we're going to be
building on Jackie Baker's
can't quite say how they got their
impression on whom I have encouraged
them down that road
um
I mean the site's quite as a quite an
interesting history it was it was uh
it's included in an options report going
back to 2015
um when it was supposedly going to be
brought forward in 2015-16 so I'm afraid
that the wheels of local government have
moved rather slowly in this case
um I do note that all the ward
councilors voted for it to become
housing land when the local local plan
came forward in draft form in 2018 and
when the local plan was approved in 2020
so obviously they all like the idea of
houses there because they voted for it
um I do think we just need to make clear
although we understand this that Jackie
Baker's is not housing land and I'm sure
that there's nobody on this Council who
thinks that houses should be built on
Jackie Bakers or has any plans to bring
forward such
mad ideas
um I do have I am a little big I mean I
I've struggled with the the minimum
Revenue provision and the capital
financing requirement I do understand
the principle of what's behind them but
I do find the report a little bit
confusing and not only because it's not
sequentially numbered
um it goes from 2.9 back to 2.5 and
starts again so that makes it a bit more
confusing at 2.8 it seems to suggest
that um
the reduction in the revenue cost of the
annual amount of the minimum Revenue
provision means the saving can be
utilized to undertake additional
borrowing to support the Jackie Baker's
development that would seem to imply to
support this project under the HRI and
then in the recommendations at 3.2 it
says the additional borrowing
capabilities of the general fund of
between 489 and 611 K could be utilized
for future improvements at Jackie Bakers
which I read to mean to the sports
ground so can we be clear which we're
saying because I'm afraid it's clear as
mud to me but generally speaking I
support this thank you
sure what happened to the numbering here
but um
uh maybe
um well I'll hand back to councilor
bayford and she might refer it to thank
you councilor rip for your support um
this is another illustration of this
administration's commitment to providing
affordable housing which is much needed
by many of our residents I'd like to
defer to either to
um
right okay thank you very much
um but just to clarify what we're saying
is that um so I I mean I do understand
the the confusion about the
um the finance the capital financing
arrangements and
um I'm sure Mr Blundell can explain it a
bit better than I can but in principle
we already own this site so we're not
buying it the HRA is not buying it from
the general fund the council already
owns it
um but of course the um the capital
financing requirement requirement deals
with the amount of borrowing that's
allocated either to the general fund or
the HRA so
um what will happen when we transfer the
land is that those those allocations of
borrowing will be adjusted to reflect
the the value of the land being moved
across from one account to the other
um
what um the report's also saying that as
a consequence of that the the revenue
costs within the general fund were
reduced because it's supporting less
Capital uh less less borrowing and that
additional Revenue capacity could be
used to support further borrowing in the
future if the council was minded to do
do so and that further bothering
borrowing could be used to invest in the
sports facilities at Jackie Baker's
hopefully that clears out
I'd just like to invite Mr Porter to
apply for job and finance anytime soon
so are you saying um Mr Blundell that
you you don't wish to add anything to
the eloquence I couldn't have described
that better swanse you um in short
Capital financing is horribly technical
local government borrowing is horribly
technical but as Mr Porter explained
effectively this gives us some more room
to borrow in the general fund and that
could be used amongst other things for
investments in sports facilities at
Jackie Baker's if we chose to do so
I understand that side of it I don't
understand why the what the report says
when it says that that it could support
the Jackie Baker's development are we
saying there's a financial benefit to
both the general fund and to the housing
revenue account or just to the general
fund just to the general fund okay so in
actual fact it's it's a little bit of a
it's a little bit of a stretch isn't it
we're basically saying we could borrow
some money we could spend it at Jackie
Vegas we're not making any commitments
though
so
um there goes local Authority accounting
you know it's a
um I think wiggle room yeah
um we like a we like wiggle room
especially when we get to budget time
again but um I think maybe I could
suggest slight Amendment on 3.2 to say
future improvements at the sports
facilities within Jackie Bakers would
that be
because Jackie Bakers is
just so that I don't get another 100
residents writing to me about
to go on top of the 200 that I got in
one day through the Mischief I mean I I
must admit the the forward because we we
know what it was about that's why maybe
it wasn't specific enough regarding the
forward plan and but I think there was a
little bit of Mischief making maybe
um but obviously we wouldn't be doing a
very good job if we only Built 22 houses
on the entirety of Jackie Baker's I mean
they would be they they would be pretty
huge huge affordable housing I mean they
would have you know affordable on a
couple of million bases each but so they
would have had big Gardens but um if I
may uh for your report is that okay
um recommend that slight Amendment on
the minutes Charles so
um I believe it was only you to speak
under that Council Everett so it has
been moved can I have a second councilor
David Saunders do members agree
[Applause]
ticking along ah commercial waste
item eight councilor Bob bayford
bayfords are busy tonight
thank you leader
um yeah in in 2018 TDC made the decision
to introduce a commercial Waste Service
to the businesses of thanet the
intention was to provide local
businesses with a fairly priced yet
flexible service while supporting The
Wider provision of services within our
Recycling and waste functions
unfortunately during a period between
2018 and now the country has faced
multiple challenges that have impacted
on the provision of this local service
and these include although not
exclusively brexit and the national HTV
shortage this is at a significant impact
on our ability to attract and retain
drivers for local positions both
permanent and temporary the covid
pandemic this directly impacted on local
businesses ability to trade their way
through the pandemic resulting in them
closing for a period or in some cases
cease in trading altogether this has had
a direct impact on the number of unpaid
invoices and the size of our customer
base
National cost of living crisis this too
has had a direct impact on businesses
ability to continue trading again adding
to the amount of default debt and
reducing our customer base
all of these things have made it
difficult for us to maintain our
original objectives and as a result
we've been trading at a loss it's
therefore considered prudent to withdraw
this service and focus on our statutory
responsibilities allowing businesses
time to find an alternative provider
that can meet their needs so I therefore
recommend option one of this report
which is to cease offering the service
from the 31st of May 2023 which will
provide two months notice to customers
as per the terms and conditions
discontinue the commercial Waste Service
and charge customers at the 2022-23 rate
until such time as a service is
withdrawn the last point there is the
fact that in fees and charges that went
through the budget time there were going
to be increases to the charges but it's
still prudent just to leave them as they
are it's a much more convenient
administratively and probably would only
add insult to injury when we're taking
service away from people thank you so I
moved here
thank you um councilor Bay bayford to
speak under 20.1 councilor Bailey
thank you
um yeah I mean I fully appreciate the
the arguments for stopping the service
it's a shame really but it's obviously a
lost maker and it impacts on other
services
um I just wondered if we know
um the available capacity of private
commercial waste companies if there's
enough capacity to take on this um I
don't know what percentage we we have in
the district
um and these two months notice a
sufficient amount of time for these 300
plus businesses to find a new provider
um obviously the worry if if there isn't
is the uh it's about the rise in fly
tipping
which is acknowledged in in 3.2 the
report
so and making it it says in that in a
comment that there will be a need to
focus on flight shipping from the street
scene enforcement
um again my concern is the department is
already overstretched so will there be
any additional Manpower at least for the
initial change over period
thank you
thank you and councilor Bailey councilor
Bay Bay yeah thanks leader um you know
Council by the fact is that um you know
it's absolutely the right decision to
stop this service
um I've got every confidence that
there's plenty of capacity there's lots
of waste operatives uh you know
commercial waste operatives that operate
in thanet and indeed I think we've
actually had some interest from uh these
these people to see whether they might
take over a business which of course we
can't do that it would would be improper
to do that but I mean I certainly think
that there'll be no shortage
um the issue possibly it might be that
the fact that those operators will be
almost certainly charging more than we
were charging in fact we did actually do
some modeling to look at how much we'd
have to charge to be able to keep this
running and break even and our price is
going to have to go up a little lot so
in fact I would think that rather than
businesses being subjected to that by
going to these other suppliers they're
probably going to be paying albeit more
than they're paying now but they've been
paying less than I would had we
continued with the service
um I don't know whether
Matt would like to add anything that's a
fair summary of that's the first summary
of exactly where we are I can't remember
what the other point was but um
ultimately
yeah so so with regards to that we've
already started working with the
enforcement team now so preempting the
outcome of that and we've already formed
better working relationships so that we
can be more reactive moving forward so
there are already plans in place to
mitigate the impact of that
um to a change the way we're dealing
with flight tips generally anyway so all
of that stuff is kind of in hand
um there we've been as councilor bayford
has said we've been approached by a
number of companies big companies but
also small people that are potentially
wanting to start up in that field so I I
no doubt that there's enough capacity to
pick that waste up
thank you um of course the one of the
largest users of commercial waste are is
the food industry and obviously
um to have
um
food and hygiene license you must also
demonstrate that you have certificate of
collection buying approved so it's
actually makes the enforcement side
um I can certainly remember when I had
restaurants that we would have random
visits from the enforcement in that area
so and it is important because they are
big users obviously of the service so um
enforcement is a is a real necessary uh
entity so it has been uh councilor
Auburn sorry Council Auburn I've nearly
forgot you then yeah you've been very
quiet this evening I've sat here very
quietly sure that's that's where your
mistake has been I don't know I usually
shout louder than I normally do yeah
[Music]
anyway thank you leader for that
um some of the issues that that I had
have already been answered
um so I don't want to go over those
again
um I I think it it is a shame uh I think
it was something Innovative for the
council to actually take on and do
um now I can't answer whether or not the
it's been managed properly uh whether
the finances the finance projections
were right etc etc I can't answer that
um
but I think it's something maybe we
should we should have looked at earlier
however
um
I would like just to ask a question
really
um
as to whether
any consideration could be given
for commercial waste collections uh
provided to community centers Charities
Etc the probably the council uh
undertake at the moment
um as whether that could be feasible for
that to uh can continue and so I would
just like to ask that
one question thank you
councilor Byford
yeah thank you Council Auburn
um I mean you say perhaps it should have
been looked at earlier in fact it's it's
certainly been under very close review
over the last few months and you know it
is a difficult decision to take we know
it's a popular service with the
businesses and yeah it's good good for
the council it looks good for the
council so it's going to always going to
be a difficult decision to decide to
Cease the service but when he looked at
the figures there just was no option
um so so we had to do that
um I mean I defer to Matt in a minute
but I mean I can't see a sort of partial
commercial service to Charities and so
on being feasible but I'll ask Matt
we did explore it as an option as to
whether we could provide an interim
Arrangement and it's it's not feasible
what one the vehicle that we're using is
an end of life and to take another
vehicle off of one of the main rounds to
pick this up is just it's not practical
so what I would say is this doesn't
remove the opportunity in the future to
revisit this it's just not right at this
particular moment in time with all the
obstacles that we faced
no chance in resuscitate in the Lorry
then
not sure I'm not sure
I think it's pretty resuscitated many
times counts at all for nothing
right uh well I don't know
I can't even think of something to
respond witty to respond to that so I
won't bother trying
um so it has been moved and I'm looking
for a second there councilories pew
do members agree
autumn nine HRA tablet refurbishment and
refit program retro refit gosh Supply me
this is a retro refit program sorry
counselor dual bayford to introduce
thank you leader
this report asked cabinet to agree to
the appointment of mayor's group as
design and delivery partner via direct
award using a procurement framework
this contract will provide full delivery
of a 17 million pound refurbishment and
retro retrofit program to five of the
council's tower blocks
these Works will improve fire safety
with the replacement of the external
wall insulation on fire doors in the
blocks
improve structural safety by carrying
out any concrete repairs required
improve Energy Efficiency with a number
of proposed retrofit measures including
replacing windows and Heating
and improve the condition of the blocks
through cyclical works that include
decoration to internal repairs so sorry
to internal areas repair decorate or
replace flooring and the refurbishment
of balconies
this procurement strategy is the
preferred route to Market to safeguard
eligibility
to the funding opportunities that are
open to the tenant and leaseholder
services as speed of delivery is key
we had secured funding of 1.7 million in
the government's Building Safety fund
for the pre-tender works and expect to
be awarded the forecast to replace the
external wall insulation which is in the
region of 10 million pounds and has
submitted a bid for 4.2 million from the
social housing decarbonation fund
this funding could cover 70 of the value
of the project thus providing a great
financial benefit to the council to
tenants and to leaseholders who would
need to contribute to work through their
service charges
we expect to hear the outcome of a bid
to the social housing decarbonation fund
during Mark March and if we are
successful we'll be able to return a
corresponding amount from the approved
Capital program to the HRI major repairs
reserve for investment in future
projects to improve the council's
housing stock
I recommend that Council approved the
appointments of Mia's group PLC as
design and delivery partner by direct
award using the Prosper framework and
also to approve the appointment of the
in-house delivery team as detailed in
Annex one
I I moved the recommendations of the
report
there are no speakers under 20.1 so I'm
looking for a secondary councilor David
Saunders do members agree
so the last evening for this evening is
item 10 Edgar row purchase again over to
councilor Jill bayford
thank you leader
Liv Margate is an ambitious program for
the council to intervene in the housing
market in cliftonville by purchasing bed
sets and houses in multiple occupation
and converting them into family homes
the program has proved extremely
successful and has so far converted to
nine buildings into 33 self-contained
family homes from what was previously
more than 100 bed sit Flats with shared
facilities
the program has tackled buildings in
serious disrepair contributed to
improving housing conditions in
cliftonville and let homes on long-term
secure affordable tenances the funding
for live Margate is part of the approved
housing revenue account Capital program
with the remaining approved funding for
the live Margate program we are
proposing to purchase a large property
in Edgar Road cliftonville
the property consists of four
interconnecting houses currently
configured as a single licensed house in
multiple occupation
it consists of approximately 20
individual rooms with with ensuite
bathrooms and shared lounges and
kitchens
the property has been valued and the
owner has indicated acceptance of an
offer within the valuation figure
subject to contract
there is sufficient funding within the
approved live
sorry live market program to support the
purchase
in the same way as other properties
already completed within the live
Margate program it is proposed to
purchase the property and complete a
conversion into self-contained family
homes for affordable rent
if approved the conversion project will
take between 12 and 18 months to develop
and for Works to start on site during
this time the building has the potential
to be occupied as a housing multiple
occupation to assist with the needs of
homeless people this is an exciting
project which will ultimately provide
more affordable housing for long-term
tenants but in the short term May assist
with accommodation for the homeless
uh I would recommend that the cabinet
agree sorry to proceed with the purchase
of the building use the 1.6 million
pounds remaining in the approved live
Margate program
that the design of scheme to convert the
building into self-contained two-bedroom
Flats
Progressive planning application and
appoint a suitable design team to
progress the conversion and also to
consider a further report once the
detailed conversion costs are known so
that the necessary funding can be
included within the HRA Capital program
and a contractor appointed I move the
recommendations set out in the report
thank you councilor Byford this has been
moved to I have a secondary
councilorice Pugh do members agree
concludes our business for this evening
at
um 2034 I wish a good evening to all
members and officers and I'll press has
already gone home so uh have a good
evening what remains of it and uh
see you soon